RUSSELL ARCHER: My junior
year or my sophomore year,
I couldn't imagine I would have
been traveling to Colombia.
I'm really impressed
by the broadness
of the entire project.
LU LU: Colombia was great.
I grew up in a developing
country myself,
and I think in the
future definitely
I would love to return back home
or to another country and work
on sustainable construction.
RUSSELL ARCHER: My name
is Russell Archer.
I'm a senior studying civil
and environmental engineering.
LU LU: My name's Lu Lu.
I'm also a senior in the civil
and environmental engineering
department.
SIGRID ADRIAENSSENS:
Rusell and Lu Lu
came to see me at the beginning
of the academic semester.
Lu Lu wanted to work
with form and design,
and Russell wanted to really
do things with his hands,
do physical testing,
and things like this.
LU LU: So we learn about this bamboo
architecture and construction
nonprofit in Colombia.
TIM MICHIELS: I have a good friend
who is an architect in Colombia,
and she had this set
of bamboo structures.
And she was looking
for an engineer
to help her doing
the calculations,
so she reached out to me.
I said, well, I'll see if we
can find some senior students.
LU LU: A lot of the structures
they do in this organization
are actually very innovative,
given they're bamboo.
So really bamboo is considered
the poor people's material.
They don't actually have a lot
of engineering research done
in the area yet, so
it's a nice place
where we could come in to
do some more engineering
analysis on the structures.
SIGRID ADRIAENSSENS: They worked
both from very different aspects.
Lu Lu is very interested in
design and digital modeling.
Russell, he was very
interested in the physical,
so he immediately ordered
bamboo, started cutting it up,
started testing it.
So they were doing
separate work,
but their results were kind
of influencing each other.
TIM MICHIELS: I think one of
the biggest challenges for Lu Lu
was that she basically got
to work on this material
that very few people
have worked on before
and that she was about to make
a computer model on a material
that she didn't know, and using
a computer program that she
had never used before.
And for Russell, I think one
of the biggest challenges
was getting bamboo and
then figuring out himself
how he should make
joints, how to manually,
physically reproduce
significant results that
have an impact in Colombia.
RUSSELL ARCHER: A specific
type of joint I'm looking at
is the fishmouth joint, and I'll
be analyzing its effectiveness
to resist specific
types of loading.
LU LU: I’m looking at
very specifically
one canopy they’re building.
It's of a shape of a
hyperbolic paraboloid.
I'm also going to do some
hand calculations in order
to validate the analysis results
from the computer software.
SIGRID ADRIAENSSENS: As part
of the senior thesis, they
got the opportunity
to travel to Colombia
where the structure actually
is being built at the moment.
I think that was
also very informative
for them to see that it's
not only about engineering,
but it's also about
how the communities
that these structures are built
for adopt these structures
and live with them.
LU LU: I really enjoy this project
because engineering is not
only hardcore science--
you calculate something,
and that's it.
But there is a very
strong social component.
TIM MICHIELS: I was really amazed
how much two senior students got
done in one entire year,
just dedicating themselves
to these structures in Colombia.
SIGRID ADRIAENSSENS: So when
they shared their results
with the architect
and with the engineer,
they were just amazed.
They were blown away.
So they will use
these results, I
think, to inform the
structure that they made,
but also their future designs.
LU LU: I feel like this project
made me definitely much more
confident and more informed
about the difficulties
and sort of just the
methodologies and the approach
I need in the future to
make myself more useful.
RUSSELL ARCHER: I'm
hopefully going on
to do a master's in
structural engineering,
and I'm hoping to
maybe do research
a little more on
sustainable materials.
SIGRID ADRIAENSSENS: For a senior thesis,
I think it's really wonderful
if students can do something
that's actually useful
that can benefit certain
people in certain places,
and maybe also open their eyes
a little bit as to see what
engineers can actually do and
how they can improve the world.